the project is pal associates architects
office is along Kingdom route we had the
opportunity to really work on all
building in this project we are able to
draw sons learn nostalgia for the past
we were trying to retain as much of the
old field of the building as possible
well the concept office is to create
what we term as empty office it is to
react against rigidity of about the
typical offices we approached design
office in breaking down into a series of
interesting small spaces for example the
library we created the library along the
flight of stairs what a most beautiful
part about office is the way natural
light filter into the office another
interesting visual element of the common
workspace is this very tall glass
barrier vault we need office space for
the design director then instead of
doing a typical glass box to house the
office we created interesting
architecture element well the
interesting part about offices that we
were involved in the impact design in
the Universal Studio and from there pick
up the sense of experiential approach to
design that we want to create experience
rather than neutral space for function
to happen the president is not what I
think is set the benchmark where the
designer can work to us and push
themselves beyond I think it so bring
this out to a lot more people
my advice to emerging designers will be
to always maintain a sense of passion
and we here in the design process